an 8 month long CBS News investigation
reveals a potential danger that may be
looming in the sky Kris Van Cleave spoke
with airline mechanics who say they feel
pressured by management to look the
other way when they see potential safety
problems on airplanes in some of the
cases the Federal Aviation
Administration agreed with those
mechanics Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport just outside Washington
good morning Chris
good morning let's be clear the u.s. is
in an unparalleled period of aviation
safety there has been one death linked
to a US passenger airline accident in
the last decade but in our interviews
with more than two dozen airline
mechanics they talked about a pressure
to turn planes around faster a pressure
they say can sometimes be too much and
they're blaming an economic reality of
the airline business that reality is
simply those planes don't make any money
they're not flying passengers cell phone
video captures a tense exchange between
an American Airlines mechanic and a
manager in 2017 the FAA found reason to
believe a miami-based mechanic was
retaliated against after reporting
problems that pulled several planes out
of service it is a shortcut environment
Gary Santos is a longtime American
Airlines mechanic based in New York
he says he's risking his job by speaking
on camera they tried to pressure the
individual not to write it up they'd
rather you not report a maintenance
issue right walo sometimes tense
relationship between management and
mechanics is not uncommon everyone of
the 26 our line mechanics we spoke to
two-thirds from American and the rest
from Southwest Airlines described being
pressured by managers to focus only on
the work assigned if you're working say
on on a landing gear moving it and you
notice that a flap three feet away is
leaking and you write up the flap leak
you beyond your school claims backed up
by findings in several FAA whistleblower
complaints about inappropriate pressure
in retaliate
since 2015 at the two airlines and at
least 32 other anonymous industry-wide
reports in the last four years I've seen
people walked off the job and held on
suspension for a month or more because
they reported problems that they
supposedly were outside their scope for
finding several American mechanics all
with decades on the job spoke on the
condition we not show their faces saying
they feared retaliation we have so long
have you had managers use the words
can't we skip some steps absolutely the
pressures there and you know the threats
of termination and walking you off the
airfield as they would say the mechanics
come from bases all over the country
were these for significant safety issues
or are we talking about like a knob that
needs to be tightened no significant
safety issues things that needed to be
repaired brakes damage to the fuselage
CBS News obtained a transcript of a
December 2017 Southwest employee
conference call where senior VP of
technical operations Landon it's key
acknowledged we definitely need to
repair some things with the FAA there
are some things there with mechanics
getting questioned supervisors certainly
getting questioned so again compliance
compliance compliance I think there's a
good indicator of what our leadership
tells our employees it is our highest
priority captain Dave hunt is Southwest
senior director of safety management but
you don't feel like your mechanics are
being unduly pressured or threatened
chastised criticized for finding issues
that are out of scope I think any issue
that's brought forward to us is taken
seriously and acted upon investigated
and we act on those so anyway we hear
about an instance we carefully review
those but you're stopping short of
saying that's not happening whenever
we'd come aware have a safety related
event we take them all seriously and we
act on them all the same way so there's
no
question that there's a problem former
National Transportation Safety Board
member johngoh Lea says it's unusual for
so many mechanics to speak out publicly
that would be something that would stand
out to you stand out that's that's
standing out on the top of the hill
screaming and the top of your lungs
he believes the pressure to speed up
repairs and get planes back in service
faster is a problem for mechanics
industry-wide you have two dozen I
probably have 100 over the last three or
four years that have called me with
those kinds of complaints and I'm
talking about calls from every single a
line david seymour is a senior vice
president at american safety as part of
the culture and they know that if they
don't do it safely they're not to do it
at all does it concern you that we're
hearing a different account from a
number of mechanics it's not a concern
for me because i think we have programs
in place to make sure that they can
report them you say it's not a concern
we talked to a former NTSB board member
who said based on the number of people
we've talked to and that several win on
camera isn't just a red flag he called
it a field of red flags well I tell you
is their allegations have been made but
you know and almost all of them have
been dismissed there been some issues
that we've had to address but again
there's been never been an allegation
made that American Airlines flew an
aircraft that was unsafe
both southwestern American are locked
intense union negotiations with
mechanics over pay and benefits should
people be concerned about the planes
they're getting on today well I get on
them every day so I'm not concerned well
it's like climbing a ladder where the
top rung maybe in an accident or a
serious incident every time you don't do
something away it's supposed to be done
you're climbing another rung in the
ladder and it takes several rungs when
you start getting up there the risk says
to get severe do you worry that pressure
is gonna result in an accident something
is not going to get fixed those things
keep me up at night
these mechanics tell us their real
concern is that over time this pressure
could impact the overall safety culture
now in reference to the Miami situation
at the beginning of our story American
says it does not believe that was a case
of retribution adding that mechanic is
on the job today
one FAA official told us the agency does
see some cases of undue pressure but the
belief is the vast majority of airline
employees are trying to do the right
thing
there is more on this to come beyond Wow
Chris this is so eye-opening you know
short-cut environment it's not what you
want to hear in terms of airline safety
ever no I want to hear more about it and
I thank people like Gary Santos and
those other mechanics who are speaking
out because suppose something happened
and they said well we knew it all along
at least them speaking out maybe someone
will take this seriously no three-eights
them up at night it was very frightening